welcome back outrage is our Optical
America's drag queens leave nightclubs
to take over libraries and schools for
drag queen story hours for kids the
events have become too controversial but
a third of U.S states are debating laws
that would make it harder to perform a
drag at all ladies Frontier in the
culture wars has now reached Britain's
Shores and protests erupting and drag
events for kids at the tape Museum and a
South London pub well during me to
discuss always is gay rights activist
Peter tachel drag artist vanity Von glow
thus the YouTuber political commentator
Lauren Chen let me start with you Lauren
so it's been a big thing in America this
why
well I think this is such a huge topic
right now because parents are frankly
Fed Up of the idea that just because
you're going to be called a bigot unless
you agree that you're supposed to be all
right with grown men wearing prosthetic
breasts performing for your children and
there's a lot of people who will say
Well they're just reading stories uh we
know for a fact that that's just not the
case there have been like videos from
these drag performances where there are
sex acts being simulated where there are
are there's nudity and there's even one
going on right now a viral video that
shows someone performing in BDSM gear
none of this is appropriate for children
this isn't a gay rights issue this is
simply what is proper for children If
This Were females performing these acts
it would still be unacceptable and
frankly I I'm not going to be scared
into silence and saying this is not all
right simply because I might offend some
people if you want to do this in your
own time with an adult audience that's
one thing but this is absolutely not
family fun okay so valency of Anglo I've
been I've been to a drag show on in West
Hollywood you can imagine what that one
was like very full-on very courageous
very funny had a great had a great night
wouldn't want my kids anywhere near it
when they were young yeah that's
understandable I work in SoHo in the
basement bars and
um I wouldn't necessarily want kids at
my show either it would restrict what
I'm able to say so should they be going
into schools or performing at events
with kids in in that kind of environment
well we need to be careful to avoid a
type of hyperbole that I think is taking
place in America you know cardi B is not
the same singer as Barbra Streisand and
the work that she does on stage is not
the same as the performances of Barbra
Streisand in the exact same way drag is
a broad Church there's a lot of
different performance Styles and it's
not always uh this hypersexualized
stripper-esque performance that's a big
part of the drag of burlesque
um but there's also a lot of drag that I
find it a little dull I wouldn't want to
do it but that's quite Disney princess
quite um Anodyne actually and that's
what's happening at the drag queen story
ours as I see it in the UK Peter is a
problem that uh as with all these things
there are a few examples where drag
queens have simply gone too far they get
caught on camera that becomes the
narrative and some we moved to quite a
puritanical response I mean for example
when you've got a panther at Christmas
there's normally someone in Drag and
everyone's laughing and the place is
full of Kiss so I don't think
necessarily it is always harmful to be
in a children environment but it does
depend what they're doing and some of
these clips I've seen have been I think
crossing a line well certainly here in
Britain the drag story time is very much
about encouraging young people to read
it's about using drag as a way to engage
people do we have to do that well it
makes it more fun for kids to have this
character dressed up all glamorous and
spicy to tell them stories rather than
some boring man in a suit does it prompt
too many questions though of a
sexualized nature I mean there is a
whole debate in America in particularly
Florida governor of DeSantis there and
others believing you just shouldn't have
anything
sexualized going on in in Young School
classrooms I can assure you the drag
story times in Britain have no sex
whatsoever it's just simply a man in
drag telling stories like anybody else
would wholesome innocent stories family
stories and often the parents come along
as well and the reports I've heard from
parents is they are delighted that these
drag queens have managed to get their
kids interested in Reading
appears you would have taken your kids
to see panto when they were younger I'm
sure and Lord knows I grew up loving Mrs
doubtfar and I've turned out just fine
peers
um I think that the problem is we get
this cultural hangover from the states a
lot of the time of course there are the
odd pictures of people doing the
backward splits and all that where I'm
not sure that that's the type of
performance that we're describing when
we're making a defensive drag queen
story well let me ask let me ask Lauren
on that point I mean Mrs doubtfar was a
hugely popular movie did that offend you
would you watch that with a child if so
what's the real difference
well I think there's a very important
distinction to be made between
cross-dressing and specifically drag and
I I have to say I think your guests are
aware of this difference the history of
drag is very rooted in sexualized
performances the person who kind of
pioneered drag queen Story Hour
specifically talks about using drag in
order to subvert the nuclear family
heteronormativity and in order to
implant I guess Notions of queerness in
children's brains so I'm sorry but no I
simply don't believe that this is just
about getting kids to read there are so
many different ways that we could have
initiatives to encourage literacy among
children none of which involved adult
men wearing prosthetic breasts which is
exactly what drag is well ultimately and
maybe there may be a slight cultural
difference between Britain and America
on this because the panto culture is so
prevalent here and it isn't in America
so it might be I just want to also Adams
very quickly in a society where
everything is offensive including a
white person wearing dreadlocks why is
it okay why is it celebrated for grown
men to be essentially wearing Woman face
and Performing all these caricatures of
female sensitivity so just you're
offended by it
well I think it's hypocritical for these
people who are often on the left
sorry offensiveness
are you offended I wouldn't I I am
offended of this happening in front of
children yes that does offend me very
much listen I've got to leave it there
thank you very much indeed uh thank you
both very much indeed thanks uh we
appreciate it